I don't you know you know time the [ __ ]  are you talking about  oh my and you know I'm a [ __ ] I'm I'm  crazy I like people that say like I'll  go see somebody leave a comment to my  advice say they don't I'm then I'll  follow that and then I wait like a  [ __ ] hawk this is actually my  favorite like our [ __ ] Cobra in the  grass  do you sick I am this is what I do with  my [ __ ] spare time Charles Joseph  [ __ ] wrote I don't time for this and  I [ __ ] get motivated by that follow  him on Twitter he's got eight followers  right and I watch them and then I wait  and this is my favorite time of year  this actually is my favorite time of  year because a lot of them are a lot of  them love to talk about Steph Curry and  LeBron and I'll wait and I'll wait and  then the tweet will come yo did you just  see what LeBron did and I [ __ ] strike  and I jump in I'm like oh no how time  are your time for LeBron you [ __ ]  you